this is a team that's going to have to  do this through the air it's going to be  all skylar thompson trying to get  creative  on second down  trying to see where they're gonna get  set and then it's just a simple little  lead play  and there's two oh you defenders there  and he just splits them and goes for a  touchdown  radley hiles goes too far outside and  fawn just stays skinny  close to his offensive lineman from 50  yards away  [Applause]  and kansas state takes the lead  as he scoots up into the pocket what  you're going to see is  stoops breaks it across the linebacker's  face all he's got to do is throw it and  hit him in the chest and it's going to  be a first down for oklahoma but he  throws it way too high  and a little behind stoops who can't go  up and even get a hand on it  mcpherson is right there he caused the  turnover earlier he gets this pick